Hi. I'm John Regehr and I like to make software fail. This
June I'll be teaching CS258 which is a course on applied software testing.
What that means is, the focus of the course is going to be
on trying to make real software fail as opposed to learning software engineering
theory. The reason I wanted to create this course is because computer
science educators like me, often haven't done a very good job in teaching
tCS students to become really strong testers. And I'd like to help try
to fix that. One of the things that you'll do in this class
is participate in some tournaments that we have setup, where you are
going to to try to break software that other students and they are going
to break the software that you wrote. And I think this will be
really fun. I spent the last 12 years as a computer science researcher,
mainly working on ways to improve the quality of software, including reporting
about 450 bugs to people who develop C compilers. This class is for
you if you're interested in increasing the quality of software that you write
and then increasing the quality of
software that other people write. You're ready
for this class if you have a reasonable, working knowledge of
algorithms and data structures, and if you're an intermediate level Python
programmer who can put together the basic control flow constructs and
data types in order to solve small problems. See you in class.